rodolfo mesquita foi um grande artista
pernambucano
ele era na verdade um desenhista como
ele gostava de se auto define ele tem
uma frase que eu tomei pra mim eu tomei
posse dessa frase que ele dizia nunca
tinha começado a desenhar simplesmente
nunca tinha parado
é assim que me sinto e como pra ele é a
única resposta que enche meu coração e
faz sentido é quando alguém me pergunta
o que eu faço no mundo e eu consigo
responder com todo o gosto e ainda assim
com peso nas costas só desenhadora como
se fosse aquela pergunta e resposta bem
simples e sem rodeios como a do corda
lista que a gente conhece que a fala
parece dançante e você vai ver nos
balõezinhos aparecendo a gente vê mesmo
os desenhos com a palavra inventada ali
no calor da garganta para fazer sentido
ao ofício que é genuinamente a única
coisa que liga você existência da vida
desenhadora embora só tenha aprendido a
dizer pra fora e isso faça pouco tempo e
que pra dentro eu já soubesse mas tinha
medo não dava cabimento fingia que não
estava escutando é que a vida prática da
gente tem dessas coisas
por 20 anos eu estive jornalista até
jogar tudo pro alto porque a vida veio
me cobrar vida nunca mais como adiar o
pagamento
eu desenhava desde sempre
minha mãe trabalhou no acervo
iconográfico da fundação joaquim nabuco
e eu vivi ali a minha infância pelos
jardins do museu fuçando material da
fundação e em casa aproveitando o estojo
de quinta dela eu dava acaba tudo
outra referência é que na minha casa
tinha muitos livros de cordel antologia
da literatura de cordel que era uma
paixão do meu pai enquanto ele ficava
ali folheando
s se apegando a rima a prosa o texto eu
me interessava pelo desenho pela
xilogravura
eu gostava é daquele desenho da
xilogravura comum uma falha no desenho
com a tinta interrompida no papel com
aquela textura que parece relevado no
papel revelada uma pintura que às vezes
a gente considera ingênua do traço que
parece simples mas ao mesmo tempo se
mostra uma técnica imprevisível
aquilo pra mim parecia poesia desenhada
ainda parece eu me emociono
é o traço que soa na if como se tivesse
saindo da cabeça do que você planeja
direto para o papel como se não
existisse nenhum em um escala entre o
que a gente está pensando e o que a
gente desenha é uma comunicação muito
simples né
brincava de fazer parte da estrofe fazer
um desenho eu curtia muito fazer isso
então eu lia e desenhava
isso faz parte do meu processo criativo
desde então então eu sempre crio textos
que eu acho que aí o jornalismo ajudou
depois e faz o desenho e hoje os meus
desenhos muitas vezes tem texto
o desenho pra mim era um refúgio para
essa sensação de 100 sólida que eu
carrego no mundo desde que o mundo é
mundo pra mim aquela sensação de que
faltava pertence e que ali naquele
momento do desenho eu era eu era o mundo
e tudo fazia mais sentido pra mim ou eu
não era exatamente o mundo a confusão
que a gente entende de mundo eu era paz
e tranquilidade longe do mundo que
estava lá fora criança e adolescente eu
fiz alguns cursos de atraírem acho que
era a forma de escape um direito à
orientação eu tenho guardado é achei
recentemente a minha parte
passam na 2ª bienal infanto juvenil de
arte na galeria fundar de rio de janeiro
eu tinha sete anos de idade é taxado e
se esse documento esse material me fez
pensar o quanto de desejo e desenho já
que a minha criança desenhadora muito
provavelmente foi o que fez a minha mãe
nem escrever
num desses cursos que eu fiz é eu acho
que eu tinha 11 12 anos com a artista
plástica chamada navais
ela me ensinava a noção de perspectiva
volume e eu ia na na unidade menção como
nas longas bura e e minha mão tremia no
traço é treme que só a gota até hoje
minha mão treme muito e eu ficava muito
angustiada de não conseguir ter firmeza
na mão até que ana me disse a moça hora
de fugir do que é seu porque porque você
fica tão angustiada com seu traço se
nervoso isso pode ser uma característica
do seu desenho
você tem um traço nervoso não fuja disso
e isso ficou na minha cabeça e tá até
hoje comigo meu traço continua sendo
muito nervoso pelas contingências da
vida é efetivamente eu desenhava com
lápis e um papel não tinha como negar um
lápis e um papel a ninguém então dentro
de casa isso era muito fácil pra mim
dava para desenrolar até porque também
as xilogravuras como eu conhecia não era
colorida era monocromática então tinha
bronca estava tudo certo
ao mesmo tempo que eu desenhava com
lápis e o papel eu descobri outra
técnica que era muito barata que a água
sanitária no tecido preto
a lei também edgar sando tecido
retirando a co
eu utilizo o cotonete em abrasão porque
o água sanitária ela fere o tecido
retirando a cor e não colocando
imaginando o desenho negativo
como sempre foi a forma de conceber a
imagem eu sempre consegui a imagem no
negativo e ali eu estava fazendo uma
espécie de gravação né é a sua gravura
que não me deixava em paralelo a essa
época de 10 em ação eu escrevia muito é
e e com o tempo essa prosa foi ganhando
uma conotação mais erótica
eu acho que era já a adolescência
gerando na alta mas também aquela coisa
do feminismo que não tinha nome e que
não estava ali muito claro no raso que
eu pudesse enxergar que fosse fácil
enxergar que tivesse compreensão mas que
se tornou muito importante muito caro no
meu trabalho eu era uma fuga das
convenções estabelecidas pra mim ali
dentro de casa na estruturação afetiva e
hierárquica e eu navegação né como como
o vendo aquele modelo e querendo fugir e
nêga para que eu não repeti se não
repetisse
eu precisava me afastar aquele estigma
daquela do daquele feminino que era tão
importante pra mim e que eu vi ali na
minha casa em sofrimento e isso foi o
que me salvou dali e me jogou no mundo
que é o meu mundo de arte que desenha
obsessivamente mulheres mulheres que
amadurecem como agente no tempo
cronológico que a gente tem o desenho
apenas ali só lhe dentro de mim era
refúgio era uma solidão e sobrevivência
eu acho até que o desenho é tem uma
natureza militar ele é um dos assistidos
artísticos mais solitários mais ali
ele era luta também
eu não tinha noção disso óbvio não tinha
repertório a ficha só vai cair
muito tempo depois com muitos anos de
terapia e muito mais forte quando eu me
deparei com a terapia da constelação
nesse momento como eu disse há pouco
mais de três anos
um saiu inteiro abriu-se pra mim né há
muita coisa veio à tona é respostas
foram dadas e outros levantadas muitas
vezes quando eu desenhava a desenhar
mulher eu queria mulher lhe afirmativa
empoderada é chegando sem pedir licença
mas elas não nasciam assim como eu
pensava no papel existe aquele de lei né
acabava com aquela cara às vezes sofrida
imatura amorosa e eu precisava aquelas
que elas surgissem no papel com mais
violência mas a gravação eu desenhava
mulheres que se contorciam disformes
como eu acho que eu tenho um aprendizado
como mulher que eu estava me fazendo eu
queria violência e naquele momento eu
precisava de ser a negação aquela
formatação né do universo feminino posso
de quebra de paradigmas de conseguir
resistir
então eu brigava com desenho percebi
então a minha transformação como mulher
através do desenho a minha desconstrução
e reconstrução muitas eu sou várias
tonella celas estão em mim são as fichas
que vão caindo sucessivamente ao longo
do meu caminho e assim eu vou entendendo
as mulheres que estão fora e as mulheres
que estão dentro de mim e vou tentando
equilibrar que não é fácil
a mulher que eu desejo sei com a mulher
que eu consigo ser na verdade eu
continuo brigando com desenho porque
elas continuam frustrando no desenho
muitas vezes não é uma briga constante
até hoje eu não pára de crescer e
crescer deve se deve ser isso a gente
investe alma ea gente não desiste porque
acaba sendo um aprendizado muito pra mim
um ímpeto revela
há um pare com gerar na cei o
crescimento como mulher não é linear né
ele dá voltas eu tropece
muitas vezes eu caio naquela casa do
jogo da vida volte duas casas ainda
volta até o começo do jogo é de lascar é
cansativo mas não tem o que fazer às
vezes dá um passo para trás podem ser
uma forma estratégia de você conseguir
se vingar de seguir adiante inteira e o
desenho pra mim na minha vida é a parte
mais arredia e portanto mais original de
mim mesmo
ele surgia ali na cabeça na nos
tormentos nos sonhos e ele vai como
parição no papel não tem uma segunda
chance eu não tenho o hábito de fazer
pequeno para depois ampliar eu não tenho
muito que eu não faço muito planejamento
do desenho hoje o desenho com nanquim
eu não gosto de desenhar com lápis então
não tem muita chance eo e cobrir o do
desenho como é que eles angra é o papel
eu acho ele uma agressão ao papel que é
o suporte que eu mais amo trabalhar
é claro que tem pesquisa que tem dor
doação eu sofro agora na hora que é pra
fazer o desenho é que nem na vida jogo é
o time é bom eu não tem controle total
sobre as coisas dele surge eu gosto da
sensação da surpresa além do desenho ea
paciência que eu tenho como desenhador
hora que não é muito mas só traço que
não é talhado com o nosso lo gravura
como que eu não faço gravação mas
funciona como se fosse nessa ação eu
fico sempre atrás de jeitos de parecer
eu acho que a se logra fura que não me
deixa né ela está na verdade na minha
matriz de criação mas que no meu
trabalho na maturação dos meus
pensamentos na estruturação e na
construção
n identidade como desenhador a me leva
junto para o papel como quente sei então
tem a estética da sua gravura aonde eu
me inspiro porque não sei no papel da
pontos e respiração eu enchi o papel
inteiro eu é o coloco muito traça um
papel isso deu até uma coisa muito
interessante que é o meu mundo inteiro
que me conhece a vida toda minha mãe
levava meus trabalhos para ele quando
era menor eu vou ele tem um ea gente
briga com intimidade é isso então ele
pede para eu deixar margem eu não
consigo deixar margem então eu sempre
coloco o desenho no papel todo e eu acho
que a moldura como a janela né que vai
dar pra ver isso e se esse tipo de
trabalho no exercício me cansa mas é
também um aprendizado passo eu passo
horas ali costurando as minhas texturas
me irritando com meus começos que
carecem de um fim
se eu abrir uma textura eu tenho que
fechar e foi interessante isso porque no
meu trabalho eu fiz um desenho que ele
ficou inacabado e esse desenho proposta
as pessoas me levaram pra casa e na
acabada e eu pensei é ali que eu tava
igualando a ele assim como o desenho eu
era inacabada
esse desenho se chama ensimesmada e
marcou o tempo de largar tudo pra me
dedicar ao desenho para recomeçar a
pouco mais de três anos
eu estava ali dentro do meu set estava
me já estando já estando a minha coragem
me reinventando me alimentando
umbilicalmente do que me era mais
precioso na vida eu estava para nascer
eu não desejo eu gosto também de brincar
com aquela coisa que eu falei do pensar
desenhar é pra ver o desenho surgindo
junto comigo porque desenhar alimentar
as minhas profundezas e se o ato é isso
é solitário em si é quando você está
desenhando a criação não o desenho tem
vida e decide ele na verdade tem vida
porque a criação é resultado da ebulição
do
existe na nossa perspectiva de olhar em
relação à vida da nossa alma das gentes
das conexões é da pesquisa que se faz
ali na hora do desenho um consciente ou
inconscientemente é vida mesmo ali
surgindo muitas vezes ao longo do meu
caminho como o desenhador me
questionaram também a repetição do tema
mulheres e seu esgotamento enquanto
assunto de trabalho e eu não tinha noção
de clareza de discos como eu tenho hoje
de que não nunca fui repetição era na
verdade a afirmação eu estava me
descobrindo estou vendo aqui uma mulher
na ec e se afirmar que tantas mulheres
nascendo e se afirmando junto quem vive
no mesmo planeta que eu sabe o quanto
isso é necessário enquanto a gente
precisa romper tantos paradigmas para
ser ainda mais sincera sempre
questionaram as vozes minas das minhas
mulheres do seu sexo
os pêlos se eu colocava os pêlos parecia
erotizar o desenho que o feminino
parecia carecer de infantilização
enquanto as pessoas me falavam pra faça
mulher mas não coloque ela o seu sexo
eu desenhava muitas mulheres em suas
vaginas e muitos pêlos era tanta que
isso se tornou uma característica do meu
trabalho e tinha gente que dizia eu
conheço a periquita de longe
hoje as mulheres ganharam cores é eu é
foram o papel ganhar ranhuras na corpo
que é estética com a qual o trabalho e
com o papel amarelo que virou o ponto de
partida de pouso e assim como o papel
branco é a mesma coisa o desenho tem que
tomar conta do papel todo pra ele
surgirá ele nas seis séries de trompas
uterinas mulheres que nem sempre hoje
estão consegue se consegue ser exposto
mas ainda assim são afirmativas pegando
emprestado agora outra
frase dessa vez da de um artista visual
que é gravador inclusive maria bonomi
é numa entrevista que ela deu pra
clarice lispector é quando clarice e
esteve jornalista que ela dizia estou
derrubando limites é uma fuga pra dentro
se você quiser dá medo clarice é como
brincar com a morte
obrigado
[Aplausos]